[Music]
okay so this is my review
of the new hbo max film which was
acquired from sony pictures
an american pickle this is based off of
a short story
written by simon rich in 2013
called sellout he also wrote the
teleplay here this was directed by
brandon troust this is his first
film he's directing solo he is known for
being the cinematographer on
most of seth rogen's projects film stars
seth rogen
in both lead roles here as herschel
greenbaum and ben greenbaum also in the
film are
sarah snook from succession fame and
yorma tocconi from lonely island
now if you come to watch this movie
because of sarah snook or yorman takoni
you're in the wrong place
i think sarah snook has about five
minutes in the beginning of this film
and yorma is in about three minutes a
little bit of the false advertising by
hbo max it was smart because they want
to get
sarah snook fans in there from
succession but she
is barely a player in this film she's in
the intro and that's about it
this movie is full on seth rogen if you
are not a seth rogen die hard
i don't know what to tell you here so
the story really is hershel green bomb
this jewish immigrant worker in 1920 he
falls into a vat of pickles and he wakes
up a hundred years later the same age
his body totally preserved and he looks
for family he's in brooklyn
and he finds one family member who's his
great grandson
ben greenbaum also played by seth rogen
so you have two seth rogens looking at
each other in this film so one of my
biggest problems with this film
is that i believe seth rogen is a great
straight man in any comedy film
but he is not a good funny man and i
feel like that was missing here because
herschel's supposed to be the funny man
that seth rogen is playing and honestly
i don't think seth rogen is interesting
enough or funny enough to play that part
it's not where he fits
he fits as a reactor and that's where
yeah he fits in the role of ben here
who's reacting to the crazy herschel and
you see this in all seth rogan's movies
his
moments shine when he's reacting to
anything ridiculous and he's playing
that straight man of correcting people
but when he tries to go in as the funny
guy himself
i don't feel it i don't think he's
interesting enough in that department
he's too normal in a sense and that
makes me feel like the character of
herschel suffers here
because i don't think seth rogen's the
right man for the part it reminded me of
the movie
elf with will ferrell now will ferrell
is the perfect funny man here
right he's never the straight man and if
you had someone like him playing a
herschel type role it works so
this movie felt like actually a really
just
dull boring version of the story of elf
where
a figure comes from almost like a
different time or land and is trying to
adjust and take in the big city
you've seen it a million times but
unlike elf it
leaves out the funny or fun part of it
the movie's in a very
grim color palette it's all blues and
greens here in gray
and it really fits the just feel of the
movie that it's dull and
that it never really escapes that and it
makes it really boring to watch
and it was one of those films i just
wanted to end
i thought it started okay and then 20
minutes in you're like this isn't good
and then 40 minutes in you're like how
has it only been 20 minutes
it just keeps drudging along for an hour
and a half run time which is
really just at this point unacceptable
with so many options to watch
you're going to see the reason that ben
is actually mad at herschel the main
reason
isn't that great in the sense of making
you as the audience
feel for ben a lot you kind of just like
eh and then that hurts the emotional
weight later on the emotional payoffs
it brings the stakes so low and if
you're gonna have low stakes and a
comedy that's fine but
you gotta make it funny then and it's
seth rogen doing those jokes he's in his
comfort zone with where
there's not much thought to it and it's
timely jokes but they're
really easy and anyone could have wrote
them kind of jokes referencing twitter
again referencing blogging
making stabs at hipster culture in
brooklyn because the character of ben
is based off a brooklyn hipster and the
story's
basically being told to have them both
learn from each other and him
embrace his jewish roots and then
herschel to pick up
the new values and him to kind of pick
up some of the old values
but just because you make that a good
theme
doesn't mean it pays off in the end and
because knowing it's based off a short
story
i feel like this story would really work
well as a short story
but it does not work as a film it's
paper thin here the plot it's
a classic story of him trying to get
revenge on this new being in his life
that's just a complete idiot and it
is just not funny enough to justify such
a thin plot
i also wish having a character like
herschel who
is a weird character he's off he's
supposed to be the funny one
that he had time to react to more actual
actors we know here where we only really
see him talk to
seth rogen as ben and background actors
so it's frustrating because i thought
maybe he'd
have more time with sarah snook or yorma
toconi but there
really isn't another player here for him
to work off of which i thought was a
very strange choice
i'm not like a seth rogen hater like i
think seth rogen's super talented
and i think he's one of the funniest
people listening to him on podcasts
interviews he's in talk shows i love him
as a person in that sense but
again you gotta be real too and realize
some actors are just great in certain
areas and others they're not really
meant for and i just don't
think it helped that he played the role
of herschel here as a funny man i just
don't think he is
and it's just falling on this crutch of
again
overdone so much but you have the one
dome character
and all you the humor is just the
reactions to him
like look he's an idiot again because he
did this and it gets old really quick
and you're going to see some critics
today say oh what a cute
timely story and the ending just meant
so much embracing his roots
and they're going to make us feel like
it's this great feel good story but it's
not
it's not earned enough it has that idea
it wants to do that but doesn't mean it
pulls it off and i don't think
it pulled it off in any way with the
theme i don't think it pulled off
the jokes i don't think the plot was
interesting and i just think it was a
bad movie and if even if you
think that maybe you liked how it ends
or had a really
good lesson here immoral and you felt
like it was earned
was it worth it in the entertainment
value was it worth it sitting there for
an hour and a half
not laughing and if you were laughing
more power to you but
i'd love to know because i didn't laugh
once in this film so so i would
totally avoid this film i'm giving this
one a 4.2
when you do see it let me know down
below what you thought of it and let me
know if you plan to watch it in general
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews i do tv
reviews as well i also do celebrity
interviews you don't miss any of those
and please follow me at stevewarly1 on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time